hello everyone and welcome to some wild
news from the Chess World Hans Neiman
has decided to sue everyone and by
everyone I mean a a lot of people we are
going to discuss this if you guys want
to read it yourself I will put a link to
it in the description below if you
prefer reading there are some 44 pages I
will just go through it real quickly uh
to give you some idea of what's going on
here you can see on his Twitter profile
Hans Neiman has posted that uh uh well
he said my loss which speaks speaks for
itself and then you can click on it and
there you can check out the law so it's
a listed on a
courtlistener.com and when you click on
it you basically get this so there we
have it Hans moken Neiman the plaintiff
and the defendants are Sven Magnus
Carlsen AKA Magnus Carlson the play
Magnus group chess.com Daniel Ranch AKA
Danny wrench and Hikaru Nakamura as the
defendants so basically the complaint is
plenty of Hanson
by and through his attorneys over the
novel blah blah blah and the local
Missouri Council the Gartner Law Firm
alleges upon information and belief as
follows so the nature of the action
Neiman is a 19 year old self-taught
chess Prodigy he brings this action to
recover from the devastating damages the
defendants have inflicted upon his
reputation career and Life by uh
egregiously defaming him and unlawfully
colluding to Blacklist him from the
profession to which he has dedicated his
life now uh as I'm not a lawyer and I
have no idea how this stuff works I'm
pretty much just gonna read what the uh
the the the lawsuit says so uh in 2014
Neiman became the youngest ever winner
of the Tuesday night Marathon at the
Mechanics Institute chess club the
oldest chess club in the United States
earning him the title of U.S Chess
Federation Master by December 2020 fide
the international governing body of
professional chess awarded Neiman its
highest Honor by naming him a chess
Grandmaster by October 2022 fee they
ranked Neiman as the 40th best chess
player in the world tied for the fourth
youngest player in the top 20. uh
Neiman's chess's Neiman's life his gift
for playing chess earned him a
scholarship to the prestigious Columbia
grammar and Preparatory School in New
York City that's cool he could only
attend by simultaneously working
full-time to support himself financially
since the age of 16 niemann's sole means
of supporting himself has been from the
money he makes teaching chess and
participating in chess tournaments prior
to the events giving rise to the to this
complaint Niemann lived out of a
suitcase traveling in the world to
compete in chess tournaments defendant
Sven Magnus Carlson is a 31 year old
chess player from Norway he is presently
the five-time rating a reigning world
champion and the highest ranked chess
player in history Carlson has exploited
his notoriety and success in chess to
create an incredibly lucrative Global
brand and online chess company the play
Magnus group uh or play Magnus prior to
the acts of uh prior to the acts giving
rise to this complaint play Magnus
probably adopted Neiman as one of its
brand ambassadors over the years play
Magnus has grown into one of the two
largest online chess companies in the
world second only to the multi-billion
dollar Behemoth chess.com LLC chess.com
in August 2022 chess.com agreed to
acquire playing Agnes for nearly 83
million dollars and merged the two
companies in order to monopolize the
Chess World Carlson having solidified
his position as the King of Chess
believes that what it when it comes to
chess he can do whatever he wants and
get away with it number six on September
4 2022 Neiman soundly defeated Carlson
during an in-person game at the
prestigious singfield captures
tournament in St Louis Missouri number
seven notably this was not the first
time that Neiman beat Carlson at just
just the first time that he did so at a
feed a sanctioned event Neiman's upset
Victory effectively dashed costs and
still remaining statistical Ambitions
namely achieving the 2900 feet a
performance rating for the first time in
history and breaking his own world
record unbeaten streak in fide
sanctioned events these accomplishments
if achieved would have solidified
Carlson as arguably the greatest chess
player of all time and made his uh
burgeoning chess Empire even more
valuable making matters worse for
Carlson Neiman embarrass Carlson by
playfully taunting him uh during his
post-match interview number eight and
notorious for his inability to cope with
defeat Carlson snapped enraged that the
young Neiman fully 12 years his Junior
dared to disrespect the King of Chess
and fearful that the young Prodigy would
uh further blemish his multi-million uh
dollar brand by beating him again
Carlson viciously and maliciously uh
retaliated against Neiman by falsely
accusing Neiman without any evidence of
somehow cheating during their in-person
game and demanding that the organizers
of the sinful cup immediately disqualify
Neiman from the tournament
uh when tournament officials refused to
comply with Carson's corrupt and
cowardly demand the baselessly eliminate
Neiman from competition causing lashed
out again this time by boycotting the
remainder of the single cup in protest
an unprecedented act for a top chess
professional let alone a reigning world
champion Carlson then confirmed his
defamatory accusations against Neiman
with a provocative post on Twitter which
had the intended effect of the
disseminating cause and false
accusations that Neiman had cheated
against him across the globe number 10
days later Carlson was scheduled to play
Neiman again in the uh Julius bird
generation cup rather than seek to
redeem himself from his unexpected loss
to Neiman Carlson the King of Chess
gutlessly forfeited the game after
making one move and then issued a press
release repeating his false accusations
that Neiman had cheated against him at
the scenefield cup number 11 Carlson's
unprecedented actions coupled with his
unfounded accusations sent shockwaves
through the Chess World and instantly
thrust Neiman into the center of what is
now widely reported as the single
biggest chess scandal in history 12th
due to his unparalleled stature and
influence in the chess Community Carlson
knew that the public would believe his
accusations of cheating against demon
even though Carlson had no legitimate
basis to believe Neiman actually cheated
against him he could ensure that no
reputable chess tournament would invite
Neiman to compete in the future and his
false accusations would cause other top
chess players to boycott Neiman as well
number 13 following Carlson's defamatory
accusations a flurry of independent and
unbiased sources including determined
tournament organizers and Arbiters of
the sinful cup fide and the world's
foremost experts in qi detection have
uniformly confirmed that there is no
evidence that Neiman cheated in any of
his games against Carlson including at
the scenefield cup particularly given
the more the ample anti-cheating
security measures used at the event
unbiased top chest and analyst analyst
have a dissected demons Neiman and
Carlson zinfeld Cup game in excruciating
detail and concluded the Demon's Victory
resulted more from Carlson's
particularly poor play than Neiman's
particularly exceptional play 14
nonetheless following Carlson's baseless
and reliatory accusations Carlson
Unleashed his media Empire to Fan the
Flames of Carlson's cheating accusations
drown out the legitimate evidence
refuting them Blacklist Neiman from top
level chess tournaments and protect at
any cost his eponymous play Magnus brand
and status as King of Chess almost
immediately thereafter chess.com in
collusion with Carlson and play Magnus
immediately banned Neiman from its
website and all of its future events to
lend uh Credence the causes absence
unsubstantiated and defamatory
accusations of cheating B defendant
Hikaru Nakamura hs.com's most
influential streaming partner acting in
collusion with Carlson and chess.com
published hours of video content
amplifying and attempt something to
bolster cousins false cheating
allegations against Neiman with numerous
additional defamatory statements and
chess.com's exec executive Danny wrench
issued defamatory press releases and
leaked the defamatory reports to
prominent press Outlets falsely accusing
Neiman of lying in his post-match sing
World Cup interview regarding his use of
a chess engine in a handful of
recreational online games when he was a
child to bolster Carlson's absence
unsubstantiated defamatory accusations
that Neiman cheated against him at the
seeing field cup
so number 15 uh despite the falsity of
defendants accusations defendants
malicious defamation and uh unlawful
collusion has by Design destroyed
Neiman's remarkable career in its prime
and ruined his life as a result of play
magnets and chess.com's collusion to
Blacklist him from chess Niemann can no
longer compete in any online chess.com
or play Magnus tournaments and will not
receive invitation invitations to
in-person events sponsored by chess.com
or play Magnus which collectively
comprise the majority of fideous ancient
chess tournaments already based on
defendant's defamatory accusations the
chess.com Global Championship revoked
Neiman's invitation to play in that
tournament in October 2022 even though
Neiman earned that invitation through
his exceptional play Team a teenage
Grandmaster Vincent Heimer canceled his
upcoming game with Neiman in Germany the
Tata steel chest tournament one of
chess's most prestigious tournaments
immediately sees the its ongoing
arrangements for Neiman to play in its
January 2023 tournament and Neiman
cannot obtain employment as a chess
teacher at a reputable school so number
17 accordingly Neiman asserts the
following claims against defendants
slander libel unlawful group boycott
under the Sherman Act for uh
tortillas interference with contract and
business expectancies and five civil
conspiracy so obviously if someone knows
what all of this is I have some idea but
obviously not um not the the cleanest
one uh number 18 Neiman seeks damages in
an amount to be determined at trial but
no less than 100 million dollars so yes
I I thought it was first I thought it
was one hundred thousand dollars but
then I thought that there were no commas
they were all
um uh you know 100 and then three zeros
then three zeros so yeah I guess it is
100 million dollars yeah it would be
silly to ask one hundred thousand
dollars for such a big lawsuit but okay
here you have the parties plaintiff hand
smoke and Iman is a natural person and a
Connecticut resident then you have the
defendants and Magnus Carlson natural
person residing in Norway then defended
to play Magnus as the play Magnus group
is in Norway a liability company founded
and owned in whole or in part by Carlson
then the defendant chess.com a Nevada
limited liability company with a
principal place of business in Mountain
View California upon information and
belief chess.com's members reside in
Utah and California 23 defendant Daniel
wrench AKA Danny wrench is a natural
person residing in Yuda and the
defendant Hikaru Nakamura natural person
residing in Florida
so there you have it uh then uh here we
have um uh the the key players and their
roles here we have uh some stuff about
fide how um yeah is the governing body
and they uh well basically uh the the uh
ELO ratings that players acquire are
only acquired at feed a rated events and
feed normally does not interfere in
other tournaments but here you have it
prior to 2021 fide only officially
sanctioned matches and tournaments that
were held in person with participants
playing uh their matches over the board
or physically sitting across from each
other and moving their chess pieces by
hand fide employs strict anti-cheating
procedures such as screening players for
men metal and electronic devices
broadcasting games with time delays and
tightly observing uh the players during
the matches currently the vast majority
of official fetus sanctioned events are
still conducted in person with only a
few select events taking place online
feed a sanction event
uh theater sanctioned online events also
employs strict anti-cheating protections
to ensure that those online matches are
played fairly Neiman however has never
participated in a fide sanctioned event
that was not over the board the
day-to-day operations of each of the
fetus action tournaments are run by
tournament organizers in conjunction
with fide tournament organizers are
responsible for among other things
tournament Logistics security and
anti-cheating or fair play measures
uh chess.com and its economic dominance
in the Chess World outside of official
chess events and tournaments sanctioned
and regulated by fide the authoritative
the authoritative body governing
professional chess there are a large
variety of websites and online
applications including chess.com on
which people of any skill level novices
enthusiasts and professionals alike can
play recreational chess over the past
three decades these casual chess
platforms have seen a meteoric rise in
popularity largely due to the ease in uh
with which they allow individuals of all
skill level to play recreational chess
quickly and easily without others with
others all over the world through a
series of acquisition chess.com has
become by far the world's largest and
the most popular online chess company
chess.com currently has more than 90
million members who play over 10 million
online chess games on its website each
day this is more than three times the
number of games hosted by the next
largest website leeches.org which is a
free and open source website Main by a
non-profit organization to attract
members to its platform at chess.com
solicits top chess professionals from
all over the world to play recreational
chess matches and create content on its
platforms pursuant at the streaming
partner agreements players with
streaming partner agreements create
content including articles interviews
and streaming videos during which top
players play Chess Live or offer
commentary regarding topics of Interest
the chess fan chess.com employs many of
the world's most famous competitive
chess players including Carlson and
Nakamura uh chess.com allows members to
follow their favorite chess players for
easier access to those players games and
content Nakamura for instance has over 1
million followers on chess.com and
Carlson has over 64 000 uh followers
while cheers.com provides an online
rating system for its members the rating
system is completely separate from and
has no bearing whatsoever on a player's
official feed a performance rating radar
players chess.com rating is a private
and unofficial tool that members can use
to help identify and play other
chess.com members with roughly the same
skill so there we have it a lot of stuff
about about chess.com uh What uh is
there anything else we could see here
blah blah blah blah blah you guys are
welcome to check it out I would like to
read the entire thing uh
uh yeah okay over the years play Magnus
expanded it's reached in the Chess World
by acquiring other chess website and
chess content creators in 2019 play
magnets acquire the chess websites the
chest 24 and chestable.com uh
chess24.com is one of the most popular
chess websites worldwide and hosts one
of the two largest internet chess
servers other than chess.com in 2020
play Magnus expanded further by
acquiring the Us website each.net in
2021 play Magnus acquired the Dutch
magazine new in chess and the publisher
Everyman chess
uh as that it stated on its website cost
and through play Magnus United some of
the most exciting chess Brands and
platforms into one strong ecosystem to
grow the sport of Chess under his own
personal brand play magnus's explicitly
stated the mission is to define the
future of Chess uh so there you have it
on July 19 2022 Carlson announced that
he would not defend the Chess World
Championship title that he has held
since 2013 instead Crossing would focus
on two personal goals goals that he
believed would solidify his stature as
the greatest chess player of all time
breaking his own world record unbeaten
streak of 125 consecutive video
sanctioned matches and achieving an
official video performance rating of
2900 which has never been accomplished
in the history of chess
then you have uh a bit more about
chess.com streamer Hikaru Nakamura here
you can read about that then a bit about
Neiman's in his meteoric rise from child
prodigy to feed it up for the player uh
then you have
um uh chess.com's merger with play
Magnus the monopolize chess so we've
discussed this conversation between
Magnuson and Danny uh all right uh what
else is of great interest to us and even
a surprise absolutely a single cup okay
we've discussed this quite a lot uh
Carlson responds by falsely and
baselessly accusing Neiman of cheating
we've also covered that there's the
famous tweet by Jose Mourinho we've
talked about this quite a lot uh Carlson
enlists his new business partnership.com
and co-conspirator Nakamura to bolster
his false accusation that Neiman cheated
against him so okay this is uh I mean
also uh you you can read this if you
want to after Carlson succeeded in
laying the groundwork against Neiman
which his initial defamatory accusation
of cheating he unleashed the full force
of his newly broadened media Empire to
publicly bolster those allegations and
drown out any legitimate sources of
opposition that demonstrated why
Carlson's allegations were untrue
immediately after Carlson announced his
withdrawal from the sinful Cup in a
manner maliciously calculated to
communicate to the world that Neiman had
cheated during their match chess.com
banned Neiman from its website deleted
Neiman slank account and forbade Neiman
from participating in any further
chess.com event
Now by Design This Southern band at the
precise time that Carlson accused Neiman
of cheating against him added instant
credibility to Carlson's false
allegations and suggested that they were
true otherwise uh there would be no
reason for shells.com to suddenly ban
Neiman immediately after uh he defeated
Carlson the bolster his unprecedented
joint ban which effectively blacklisted
Neiman from professional chess Nakamura
leveraged his platform as chess.com's
top streamer and credibility as a top
chess player to engage in an all-out
Blitz of defamatory accusations the
further confirm that Carlson accused
Neiman of cheating and to make it appear
that those accusations are true then you
have a bit more about that
you can you can check it out yourselves
uh a lot a lot of details here uh let me
see if there's uh okay those are the the
conversations between them we've covered
that as well defendants continue to
defame after another match with Carlson
all right we've also covered uh let me
just check what is this Carlson issues a
statement explicitly accusing an Iman of
cheating against him and confirming his
intentions to Blacklist Neiman from
professional chess we also had that what
is this chess.com wrench and Nakamura
republished Crossings false accusations
that Lugi is nieman's Mentor and helped
him cheat we've also covered that
all right so this is all pretty much uh
everything that's been happening for for
the past months the for the past month
that you all pretty much know uh
defendants defamatory accusations have
destroyed niman's life there there you
have it a bit more about that how how it
affected him uh first cause of action uh
slander against all defendants so uh I
guess so the first cause of action is
slander against all defendants uh then
you have second cause of action is
liable against all defendants uh then
you have the third cause of action is
violation of the Sherman Act against all
defendants then you have obviously the
fourth cause of action towards this
interference with contract and business
expectancies against all defendants uh
then you have fifth cause of action
civil conspiracy against all defendants
and uh there you have it uh we're for
Neiman hereby requests that the court
Grant him the following relief so on the
First Act a cause of action a money
judgment in favor of Neiman against the
defendants the specific amount of which
to be determined at trial but no less
than 100 million dollars plus
pre-judgment interest on the second
cause of action also 100 million dollars
plus prejudgment interest and the third
cause of action uh also 100 million
dollars plus pre-judgment interest uh uh
on the fourth cause of action on money
judgment in favor of Neiman against
defendants the specific amount of which
to be determined at trial plus free
judgment interest and on the fifth cause
of action also 100 million dollars plus
a pre-judgment interest an award of
Neiman's cost expenses and reasonable
attorneys fees incurred in connection
with the this action and any other and
further relief as the court deems just
and proper so there you see quite a lot
of uh quite a lot of millions in there
so that's pretty much it those are the
44 Pages you guys can check it out I
will put a link into it in the
description below uh I at first I
thought it was someone someone making a
joke but then I saw it was a Neiman's
own Twitter account and then he did that
he published it himself they would have
it once again my lost speaker my losses
speaks for itself uh so that's what's
happening and that's what we will uh
probably be discussing uh for the uh for
the foreseeable time uh so yeah what do
you think about this do you have this
has any Merit uh or or you know it's uh
well I'm always interested in hearing
what you guys think uh what do you think
will happen how long do you think this
might last do you have any ideas in
international law uh like I'm very
interested in in what will come of this
and you know do share your opinions as
that what that's what the comment
section is for uh so yeah that's the the
video uh on uh well just basically
updating you on what's happening in the
world of Hans Neiman versus everyone I
hope you guys enjoyed that I would like
to wish a very happy birthday to jjorn
Bergman and I would like to thank
ravishing reptiles YouTube Trevor
Terrace luxemina and chakrapani and Alan
psycho for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day